Hi, everyone. In this lesson, we're going to go and take a look at the Spotlight and
the Rec Light, and a few other tools that we can use when it comes to working with
our properties and settings. So let's get started. So back into Unreal, we can see
that we have the Point Light also as an option and the Rec Light. Let's look at
these up close. So I'm going to go ahead and drag a Point Light into my scene. Now,
this is just a raw Point Light from the very beginning. And the Point Lights I must
point out to you, no joke intended, is the fact that they are actually kind of
expensive. So when you use them outside of Mega Lights, you'll actually kind of
see as you analyze your scene, if you have multiple ones in there, they can
get pretty expensive overall. So I recommend if you do have to use a lot
of them, try to use Mega Lights when you can. Now remember, Mega Lights is
still in beta, and it's in the early stages. So tread cautiously. But for the
most part, just keep those things in mind. It is, the way that it works is
kind of like an omni light, we're able to control our intensity for sure, as
well as candelas. If we wanted to switch those into a different intensity
unit, we can. We also have the color as well as the attenuation radius. So
we can control how far out this light influences its area. We also have the
source radius. And this allows us to control almost like controlling the
hotspot of this light, the strength as it shows in our reflective surface
here. But we can also control our soft source radius here where we can
soften those reflective surfaces. Now you got to be careful when you do
adjust these and say you don't want a physical physical shape to show up, you
will kind of get maybe you'll kind of get a feedback where it looks like my
rim light isn't quite looking the way that I want. So you're gonna have
to do a happy adjustment between these two between changing the shape, if
you needed it large, or etc, in a particular shape, and then how you're
going to result, get your soft source radius to work with that. So
it actually is believable. And it's up to you, you may want a nice
hotspot to it, as you can see me lower it, or you might want to
soften it, it's up to you. But there's also a thing called length.
So let me actually control a bit of the radius here, make it a little
bit smaller here. And you can actually see in my example, I have a
light here that has a shape change. And you can change that
simply by me selecting this particular individual. And I can go
to my source length. And I can make it so this light is kind
of stretched over a shape. And the nice thing about this is I
can actually make it so it's some sort of tube lighting, or as
you can say, a very cheap lightsaber. And you can add this
like office lighting into an environment by simply changing
the shape. Now if you're baking, you got to be careful
because if you change the shape, your shadows may get a
bit pixelated as you bake things out. But if lumen handles
it pretty well with the shape changes, so just keep those
things in mind. We can also use temperature affects the world
cast shadows, indirect lighting intensity, and volumetric
volumetric scatter intensity for if we how we want this,
how powerful we want this to be influenced by fog. Awesome. Let
me go and delete this guy. And let's go ahead and create a
rec light. Now actually, I'm going to use the one that's
in our scene, we don't necessarily have to make a new
one. So let me drive over here. Look at there's a fella
here. So this is the rec light, one of my favorite
lights to work with. They are the one of the more
expensive lights work with because it's like a series of
point lights trapped within this rectangle shape. The nice
thing about this is you can quickly get a nice fill light
for your environment. You can see as I'm moving this around,
you can fill have a nice little extra light based in our
scene to be able to make those filled areas that you
need. And it works really great. And it's fantastic. So
it's the equivalent of what you'd see like a volumetric
light and 3d Studio Max and Maya. Although unfortunately, like
in 3d Studio Max, you can't really turn off the
influence area of the hotspot. In that particular case, you
have to control the spec that may not give you exactly what
you need because you can lose some of your highlights.
But that's what you would do if you wanted that shape to
be doled down a little bit. Unfortunately, we do not have
that option like in 3d Studio Max, which is an offline
render to be fair, allows you to turn off that shape and
reflection. So we're not quite there yet. You're able to add a
texture though, which is actually kind of nice, as well
as be able to control our source width. And you'll see
that if I hit the spacebar here, you got to be careful
that I'm mentioning this because your source width is
primarily here. So if you hit the spacebar and say, force
of habit, like 3d Studio Max and, and Maya and you're
like, I want to control the width, you're really just
messing with the attenuation. So just be aware that you
want to primarily rest in here the details to control
the source width, there you go, as well as the source
height. Now as you do so the light will lose energy as
you stretch it over a surface. If you switch to ray
tracing with your lumen object, excuse me with your
lumen settings inside the project, as well as like
raytraced shadows, you want to be careful also not to
punch your light into surfaces like into the ground,
you want to give that a little bit of space because
there may be a little bit of noise, not as much as
older versions of Unreal, but you just got to be aware
that you don't want too much noise coming through in
your materials and objects it's intersecting with. So
we're, again, we want to control the source height
and source width in our details. You'll also see
that we also have barn door if you want to make
things a bit more on a focal point here, and barn
door length, if you want to stretch that out a
little bit, we have that option. Now, if I was to
make again to make my light a bit sharper, I would
want to control the size of my light, you'll see
the lines get a lot sharper as I scale things
down. And as I stretch it out, you'll see that the
light loses energy based on scale. So just keep
those things in mind. That's how you can soften
that up a bit when using the rec light. And
it's really one of my favorite lights to work
with. And one I use quite a bit when working on
love, death and robots. It was fantastic and
served its purpose as well. Now, another thing
we want to take a look at here is our HDR
backdrop. Now we're just going to briefly
talk about these. HDR backdrop is a little bit
more on the architectural side of things. But
this HDR backdrop allows us to bring in a
encapsulated, let me pull this into the
scene, might take a few extra seconds to get
in. And it brings in a quick HDR backdrop for
our environment. And you can see that you can
quickly have a nice architectural HDR scene
environment set up. But there are some
limitations. Now if I move this around, say I
just move it down a little bit, you can see
some stretching that may occur and you just
have to be careful with this. And if you were
to use it in a game scenario or a film
scenario, you might want to make it so it's
behind a window you can see stretching on the
trees here or farther out so that it's hidden
because it is pretty fake overall. But it's
used mostly by our product. Our clients that
advertise products such as phones and cars and
architecture, and ones that are not so
dependent on exploring the world like in a
video game, or the camera traveling over an
environment like with a film. But it gives you
the ability to control its intensity if you
need it, as well as size if you want to tweak
the size that you can. But remember, this is
wrapping your scene in like a box a cube map.
So there are some limitations on what you can
do. And your directional light will need to be
adjusted distance wise as well as our overall
size and scale of this particular HDR to get
that direction like to play nicely with the
scene. You can use camera projection if you
want there, it shows you the mesh that it's
referencing. All these things can be adjusted,
edited and tweaked as you need. And but for
the most part, again, it may not be what you
want for a game and it may not be what you
want for linear content. But it is available,
especially if you want to show things off in a
architectural setting. It places that HDR smack
dab in your scene to be able to give you the
balance that you may require. So let me go
ahead and get rid of this guy. Another one we
have is the sun and sky. Now, if I did just drop
this in my scene, there are some things you
need to consider. It's conflicting. And you'll
see Unreal mentioned that it's conflicting
with other directional lights. So I'll have to
go in here and edit my other directional lights,
one of them and switch it to forward shading
so that Unreal knows which one is going to
be affecting my environment. And I can do that
with the defaults. Or I can simply go in here
ahead of time and got my lighting and from
there, try to tweak it out the way that I
want. In this particular case, I can remove
my directional light, bring it in. So in this
case, let's grab I'm going to turn him off
temporarily. And then we're going to go
ahead and pull on these. Oh, not the skylight
already got that this guy, Sun and Sky, my
bad. There you go. Got to follow my own
advice. And then from here, we can choose
the time of day, solar time, we can adjust
that in our environment. Now again, if I
wanted to, I can rebuild my sky again, and
try to get sky to play nicely. But what's
happening here is because I haven't
determined which directional light I'm
messing with, I'll have to go into my
blueprint itself, find that directional
light to reference. And I want to make
sure that I turn on forward shading. And
I can set that to maybe one and hit
recompile. Now you may again see a
disconnect. Let's put that back to zero
for now. If I didn't want that to relate
to my scene, you may see a disconnect.
When you do that, let's turn our
directional light old one back on. And
you may have to refresh or rebuild
your environment lighting, like I'm
saying. And I'm going to recompile
again, I'm going to go to the original
directional light, and you'll see what
I'm talking about with that forward
shading, you're basically telling Unreal
which one to use for environment and
which one not to. So I'm going to do
it with our original and set this to
one. Now you'll notice it's not really
refreshing, refreshing necessarily the way
that we want. So you'll have to go in
here and do some editing. Now, this
isn't my favorite light, I think it's
kind of cool to use. And some of our
architectural clients will use it. What
I prefer is the day sequencer, which
we'll mention and talk about a bit
later. But this one allows you to get
the longitude and latitude in the
place that you want. And then from
here, you can choose what your
intensity is going to be, you can
choose your time of day, your source
angle, and so forth. And this
particular case, let's go back to this
guy, I'm in the regular directional
light here for a second. Just a
reference point, but this is mainly
what we want to play with. You can
play with the directional light here
too, if you need to. So if I wanted
to change the forward shading here, I
can. But let's go in here and mess
with the compass itself, or I should
say the blueprint itself. And then
again, we can mess with the longitude.
And we can mess with the latitude.
And you can also mess with your
directional intensity, you'll notice
it's very strong. But as I lower
this, you'll notice it's less blown
out and looking a little bit better
so that it's now relating to
environment a bit better. So just
keep those things in mind. And this
is what I meant earlier on, like you
may have to adjust your intensity
based on bringing certain lights in,
especially if you're inheriting
things from the marketplace, or say
you looked up what the time
difference is in Arizona. So those
things need to be evaluated
accordingly. So we go back to our
blueprint here. And again, you can
choose the time month. And you'll
notice it does kind of disconnect in
some angles, like that black
environment doesn't quite seem to
work really well. And it seems to
mess up the sky a bit. And so
some of these values may not work
like they used to if you're used
to using this tool. So just keep
those things in mind. We now have
it. So it's driving our
environment by switching that
forward rendering there between
the lights. And then you'll also
notice we have solar time again,
like we played with, as well as
your month. And you'll notice
some of the months are blacked
out. I don't know if it's set
for marketing purposes, like
Amazon has blacked out. And I'm
just gonna that's a dumb joke.
Alright, well, that's about it
with this set of videos here,
we're going to move on to our
next topics. Here is some links
to continue the your research
with lighting and how it works.
In the next video, we're going
to take a look at an
introduction to lumen. And
we're going to break down some
of the settings and the best
approaches when it comes to
using that tool. Thanks again.